the rest of Imran Khan has put Pakistan
on the brink here's what you need to
know
Pakistan is the Muslim world's second
most popular state and the only Islamic
nuclear state it has a big military some
seriously contentious borders and it
plays a major role regionally and
globally a resolution to the Kashmir
conflict or lasting peace in Afghanistan
wouldn't really be possible without
Pakistan playing a major role
Pakistan is in a pretty dire economic
State it's facing inflation and it's
foreign reserves have plummeted as well
it's politically
extremely polarized with regular
protests taking place and there's been a
rise in Terror attacks too and you've
got these big institutions locked in a
power struggle while ordinary pakistanis
are really struggling
[Music]
a lot of people are also still
recovering from the devastating floods
of last year and we're seeing the
poorest communities hit at the very
sharp end of climate change
foreign
what happens here in Pakistan is crucial
to Global Security no one can afford for
this state to fail but these are very
precarious times